everywhere you look these days there's
another famous somewhat glamorous
hustler being massively humiliated in a
court of law as your uncomfortably clued
in mom might say hustlers are hip but
why do we as a society hate to love to
hate on a good con artist the answer is
more inscrutable than elizabeth holm's
unblinking blue eyes and harder to
decipher than a martin shkreli tweet
just kidding we think we figured it out
so why do we love talking about these
scammers and are they folk devils folk
heroes or some weird fusion of the two
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on the scammiest scam artists alright
guys first a quick trip to the 2019 scam
artist hall of fame in cell number one
we have billy mcfarland a serial
entrepreneur from the age of 13 who came
up with life-enhancing products like
magnesis a fake credit card status
symbol that amounted to a 250 yearly
subscription to an exclusive millennial
club along with a ritzy piece of metal
you could substitute for your already
existing plastic card
sweet anyway mcfarland's entire career
as a millennial snake oil salesman
culminated of course with fire festival
the swankiest music festival that never
was
set in the bahamas fire festival
benefited from early advertising by
influencers like kendall jenner and
bella hadid who promised the sexiest
most fomo inducing event of all time
this convinced enough status hungry rich
kids to drop all their parents dough on
luxurious cabanas mcfarland borrowed
millions to finance the festival but
when guests arrived there in that
fateful day in 2017 they found a literal
concrete wasteland it was like lord of
the flies my buddy pissed on a few of
the beds on behalf of influencers
everywhere the fbi launched an
investigation which led to a hundred
million dollar class action lawsuit six
federal and four individual lawsuits
mostly from lenders mcfarland pleaded
guilty and is now hopefully planning
dope parties from his prison cell in
orange county new york while he'll be
spending six years why is fire festival
the kind of viral story even old people
like to talk about why is his memoir the
douchely titled prometheus the god of
fire probably going to make millions why
did hulu and netflix create warring
documentaries about the debacle there's
a particular shot in freuda to imagining
a bunch of rich kids eating sad cheese
sandwiches and sleeping in fema tents
and an even bigger shot in freyja to
imagine the skis who dreamed it all up
eating chile in the prison mess hall but
we're going to go ahead and say there's
probably more to it however mcfarland's
scam looks like a high school senior
prank compared to the ruse spun by our
scammer in cell number two elizabeth
holmes the world's youngest female
self-made billionaire and award-winning
female steve jobs impersonator the
timing is very ripe to change this
paradigm check her black turtleneck fake
husky voice and nine billion dollar
blood data processing company theranose
holmes's big idea was that a
fingerpricks worth of blood could be
used to run hundreds of tests that would
detect medical conditions like cancer
high cholesterol syphilis basically
anything your hypochondriac mind could
dream of never again would you have to
see a tube of your blood confiscated in
the name of medicine free at last but
not so fast leaked footage and
whistleblowers revealed that theranos
was simply conducting blood tests with
normal run-of-the-mill processing
equipment rather than any proprietary
technology also life inside the labs was
literally a bloody show basically holmes
lied about her technology and in the
process hilariously recruited
well-respected board members like henry
kissinger and general james mattis and
even more hilariously solicited enormous
investments from rupert murdoch and
betsy devos most damningly she let
shoddy diluted blood tests be processed
and knowingly gave the resulting
inaccurate information to patients thus
literally endangering their health which
is not a good look if
people are
testing themselves for syphilis using
theranos
there's gonna be a lot more syphilis in
this world holmes is still refusing to
admit any crime this is what happens
when you work to change things and
first they think you're crazy then they
fight you and then all of a sudden you
change the world we'll have to see how
that argument goes over in the san jose
u.s federal courthouse anyway the
fallout has been enough to get holmes
her fair share of press and documentary
specials and at this rate by 2022 she'll
have more biopics than winston churchill
with every blonde in hollywood from jlaw
to kate mckinnon cast to play her in
film adaptations it'd all be really
semi-glamorous if everyone didn't hate
her of course hateful fascination is in
no short supply when it comes to our
scammer in cell number three martin
shkreli former hedge fund manager drug
company exec for turing pharmaceuticals
and current proud owner of the most
punchable face in america he catapulted
to public attention when he raised the
price of daraprim a pill commonly used
to prevent pneumonia in people with hiv
aids from thirteen dollars and fifty
cents to a cool seven hundred and fifty
dollars that's over five thousand
percent you know a money-making plan you
can feel real good about then he was
accused of lying to hedge fund investors
while simultaneously siphoning millions
of dollars in assets from
biopharmaceutical company retrofit inc
to repay those investors here shkreli's
crimes are less interesting than his
post-crime antics which include
flaunting purchases like a world war ii
era enigma code breaking machine a
picasso painting and unreleased albums
by the wu-tang clan and lil wayne he
also harassed a female journalist until
twitter banned him offered five thousand
dollars for a piece of hillary clinton's
hair indicating that he wanted to clone
her he was convicted of securities fraud
and is now serving seven years in
federal prison where he is presumably
running a toilet wine multi-level
marketing scheme then in cell number
four there's the slightly less famous
but still fascinating anna sarakin
dubbed the soho grifter sorokin posed as
anna delvey a german heiress she
traveled the world pretending to be
super glamorous while chilling in ritzy
hotel rooms she had no intention of ever
paying for she also photoshopped bank
statements and attempts to secure a 22
million loan for a contemporary art
center she wanted to build ultimately
she conned banks hotels restaurants and
a private jet operator out of a cool
275 thousand dollars just by looking the
part of a rich socialite she was
recently found guilty on four counts of
larceny and theft of services and faces
up to 15 years in prison her journey was
covered extensively in a new york
magazine piece and hbo went ahead and
optioned the story because they know you
want to watch it now why are we utterly
obsessed with these people why did i
just spend upwards of five minutes
describing their seriously shady but
generally not downright depraved crimes
and why did you love every second of it
here at wisecrack we'd argue that it
largely comes down to moral catharsis to
understand the idea of moral catharsis
we first need to talk about moral
relativism or the oft-repeated idea that
moral facts i.e a thing that is always
true or always good simply do not exist
moral relativism means that moral
judgments can only be deemed true or
false from a specific standpoint or
perspective for example you might think
it's objectively morally wrong for me to
drown this guy in a pool of jell-o but
what if this guy is the inventor of
crocs from that moral standpoint aren't
i simply protecting humanity's feet from
further indignity basically nothing is
clear-cut at least in today's society
and this confusion has hit us
millennials particularly hard just ask
our therapists relativism is essentially
about the relationship between moral
codes and moral claims a moral claim
might be true in relation to one system
of moral codes but not true in relation
to another i.e we could say for a vegan
it's bad to drink milk but a non-vegan
who doesn't abide by that moral code
will drink all the teat juice they want
or one could observe that nudity is
a-okay at some beaches but morally
offensive in other communities pour this
idea through the month-old moldy coffee
filters of public culture and what you
get is a kind of paralysis or an
amorality saying that making a kid eat
his parents is right relative to eric
cartman's moral code is not a moral
claim it's just an observation it's
devoid of any actual morality it's
amoral but this is literally all some
people feel they are able to claim we're
afraid to assert moral truths in fact in
all seriousness if you do go around
making moral judgments like killing
babies is wrong people will be all like
well what if that baby is the ghost of
joseph stalin and act like you're being
closed-minded so all moral relativism
has really taught us is that the truly
ethical thing is to never assert any
ethical claims outside of your own
particular context which you'll recall
is literally non-moral or amoral as a
position
oops the plague of culturally abridged
moral relativism has been combined with
the outrage machine of social media
which bombards us with story after story
packaged specifically to generate our
most instinctive moral sentiments
outrage at college admissions scandals
horror at the way migrant kids are
treated or anger at the writers of game
of thrones at the same time we've been
told that there are no rights or wrongs
and that we each create our own moral
reality as a result we're stuck in an
ethical paralysis made more indignant
all the time but unable to articulate a
moral framework and response we don't
know how to make our own moral claims
much less stand by and up for those
claims enter 5000 word news stories
books podcasts documentaries and now
biopics about horrible people not mass
murderers though we do enjoy that too
but individuals who are just plain
conniving so blatantly and
preposterously selfish that you can
point and laugh and feel better about
forgetting your reusable grocery bag
what's more expressing these feelings in
public on or offline is pretty low risk
because people generally agree don't ask
your friend if she's vaccinating her kid
because things could turn ugly fast but
talk to her about fire festival and
she's unlikely to be like yeah that
mcfarland guy the system really wronged
that poor fella regardless of how many
or how few life-saving shots her kid has
you two can probably commiserate about
what a tool billy mcfarland is
commenting on the president's latest
tweet outside your echo chamber is risky
but nobody is going to yell at you for
calling elizabeth holmes a possibly
psychotic certainly delusional and
absolutely unblinking human being who
endangered thousands of lives in a world
plagued by political polarization and
paralyzed by moral relativism being able
to unequivocally recognize some wrongs
and have everyone agree with you well it
just feels really good in a shepherd's
pie of mushy mixed up morality these
individuals offer a rare sliver of moral
clarity enter the folk devil a term
coined in 1972 by sociologist stanley
cohen the folk devil is a person or
group whose bad behavior is rebranded by
the media as sheer evil it was
originally used to explain the way youth
subcultures like the mods a group of
london hipsters who like jazz and the
rockers were villainized in the press
after a few fights broke out between
them newspapers salivated over it moral
panic ensued and it was cathartic to be
able to point to quote actually existing
evil we'd argue that the idea of the
folk devil is more relevant than ever
not because they stir up moral panic
which they do but because they serve up
moral catharsis in other words by
functioning as cultural whistleblowers
these hustlers help us identify what's
wrong with the world around us take the
pharmaceutical industry we all know it's
a money-making soul-eating machine that
gets rich off the confusion over
medication and poor health of the
american people but with all the mixed
messages served by ads doctors pr reps
and the media it's hard to put your
finger on exactly what's so morally
wrong about it until martin shkreli
walks in and ups the price of aids
medication by again five thousand
percent with a centralized symbol of
everything wrong with the industry it's
suddenly very easy to say that they're
screwing people over which they probably
are similarly it's easy to feel weird
about the cult-like tendencies displayed
by unicorn startups in silicon valley
but hard to express why exactly a few
innovative businesses making mad bank is
necessarily a bad thing until elizabeth
holmes comes out of the woodwork with a
nine billion dollar company built on
technology that literally violates fancy
pants science laws you can't just kind
of bend your way around the laws of
physics it suggests that the so-called
innovation going on behind the scenes in
the nerd valley at least deserves our
skepticism as distilled versions of the
broader moral corruption seen in these
industries these folk devils help us
give voice to the much larger vaguer
concerns we have but can't quite express
perhaps nothing says cultural
whistleblower and moral catharsis like
anna delvey where many people might look
at high society and scratch their heads
as to how these tools became successful
here comes anna who literally proves
that the appearance of success matters
more than success itself her lawyer even
argued in court that in her world this
is what her social circle did everyone's
life was perfectly curated for social
media people were fake people were phony
and money was made on hype alone but
wait what if the reason that we're
fascinated by these creeps isn't because
they're folk devils but because they're
folk heroes now hear us out philosopher
and economist adam smith observed that
human beings innately love and admire
wealth thereby predicting the wolf of
wall street over 200 years before it
premiered what's more that admiration is
absolutely necessary both to establish
and to maintain the distinction of ranks
and the order of society so basically
we're a bunch of self-interested
ambitious dudes who won't overthrow the
system because we're too busy trying to
get obscenely rich one caveat though we
tend to balance that self-interest with
self-preservation simply put you want to
make buckets of money without making
people hate your guts in fact most of us
really desire support for our work which
is why it feels really good when your
youngest cousin tells you that being a
talking head on youtube is a cool job
thanks doug the best known derivative of
smith's principles is called yup the
american dream you know the idea that in
a free market economy everybody
regardless of their background has the
opportunity to become a rich prosperous
socialite with a fashionable address
now that all sounds great but there's a
big glaring problem most people don't
get rich much less earn enough money to
live without a weird roommate who still
plays fortnite
the american dream is just that a dream
used to motivate us to wake up each
morning and laugh at our bosses horrible
puns so then think of the scammers anna
sorkin and martin shkreli grew up in
working class homes both of shkreli's
parents were janitors and sorrikin's dad
was a lorry driver they literally rode
the scamming wave from rags to semi-fake
riches in the case of upper middle class
billy mcfarland and the wealthy
elizabeth holmes each still experienced
a massive influx of wealth they went
from silver spoons to gold spoons so to
speak meaning all of these scammy
individuals achieved the american dream
except they screwed over a ton of people
they reflect a growing frustration with
the american dream that for some it's a
fantasy that can only be achieved by
literally swindling people out of their
hard-earned cash in a system in which
most of us cannot become billionaires
the american dream boils down to raw
self-interest so in a perverse
outrageous way these folks did achieve
some knockoff soyberger version of that
dream by pursuing self-interest to its
logical illegal conclusion as a result
we both hate and loki admire their
audaciousness in our american dream
brand of reality they are oddly and
perversely enough a strange breed of
hero they grab the american dream by its
balls and screwed over innocent people
for a couple or a couple million bucks
they beat the free market economy at its
own game and almost got away with it too
and come on that's pretty gangster so
what do you guys think are these
hustlers folk heroes folk devils or some
weirdo blend of folk hero devil only
possible in our weirdo internet age
seriously tell us because we're still a
little confused thanks to all our
patrons who support the channel and our
podcast don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you